[Music]
in the series sandman from netflix we
get to see abstract and powerful
entities called the endless to which
dream or the sandman was a part of so
who are these endless
and what are their origins
let's get to it
intro and origins the endless are beings
of immense power and are timeless in a
sense that no one knows exactly where
they came to be
and have always been there even before
the current universe they can alter
their looks to conform to whatever
culture or civilization wants them to
look like a few suggestions are offered
to the precise reason they even exist
i'd rather say it is assumed that they
are natural phenomena the origin and
exact nature of the endless remain
unknown although it is explicitly stated
that they are the offsprings of time and
night
this may only be accurate in an abstract
sense
they are believed to be older than gods
and way more mysterious as well as
innately powerful
although exact ages of any of the
endless are unknown it is clear that
they have lived for a much longer period
of time than even life on earth has
the analysts are as old as the ideas
they stand for this is feasible since
they have been numerous highly developed
advanced alien civilization since long
before the planet earth was even created
dream was identified by the martian
manhunter as the dream deity on ancient
mars which occurs before the sun's other
planets have awakened with life oh yeah
did i forget to tell you the sandman and
the other endless are a part of the dc
universe the same one as batman superman
and the others so yeah back to where we
were
that asserts that she was present when
the first living creature began to move
and destiny asserts that dream gave the
earth itself the romantic notion that it
could support life so they are pretty
old
the endless spend most of their time
acting as the physical manifestations of
the forces of nature for instance
whereas dream controls the domain of
dreams and imaginations and guides
dreams and inspirations death directs
the souls of the dead away from the
world of the living each analyst has a
domain over which they have complete
authority of
each analyst has a gallery of sigils or
symbols of the other endless their
siblings inside of their domains and
uses them to contract or summon the
others in general the endless feel
uneasy in one another's territories
except in the case of an urgent
necessity to avoid entering the walls of
their siblings the only exception is
death who must be able to move around
freely in order to fulfill her duty so
who are the seven elders you may ask
well firstly there is death death
appears as a vivacious alluring and
sensible youth goth woman
he usually has an eye of horus painted
under one of her eyes and wears an ankh
which stands for the afterlife she gets
along with dream better than any other
illness and prefers to dress an act
casually ang is used as her emblem she
is not inclined to follow the rules that
the other endless do so
the next one is destiny destiny the
oldest of the endless appears as a blind
man wearing brown or gray robes and
holding a big book his chain to the book
all the books chained to him whichever
way you may prefer but neither has an
existence a part of the other the book
contains an entirety of existence past
present and future of all the endless
destiny looks the most consumed with his
role and obligations
then we come to despair seen as a small
chubby woman with grey skin and crooked
teeth despair behaves in a cool
subduedly intelligent way her emblem is
a hook ringed and she frequently uses it
to carve her own flesh the manifestation
of despair that we see in comics is not
its original form despair's original
form shared many of the same physical
characteristics as her later form and
also was a twin of desire but she was
taller and had complex red ink tattoos
she was a lot chattier than she would
eventually become which is dull and
sullen
then we come to destruction seen as a
very tall strong man with red hair who
alternates between having a beard and
being clean shaven
300 years ago destruction abandoned his
duties as an analyst which led to a
great deal of friction between him and
his siblings he lacks talon yet he is
passionate about constructive and
creative pursuits which might be the
reason why he abandoned his
function which is destruction
the sword is his emblem since leaving
his world his siblings now frequently
refer to him as the prodigal instead of
destruction
then we have desire desire can look like
either a man or a woman or neither and
is stunning thin and truly androgynous
dream and desire have a history of
animosity and cruelty
why as this is their state of relations
is unknown desire uses a heart as a logo
despite being despair's twin desire is
really older than despair in some ways
and although despair is currently in a
second incarnation
desire is in her original form
then we have delirium the youngest of
the endless delirium appears as a young
girl whose form changes the most
frequently of any of the analysts based
on the random fluctuations of her
temperament her only permanent physical
characteristic is that one of her eyes
is green with silver flecks and the
other one is blue but even though
sometimes switch between the left and
right she was once known as delight
before some traumatic event caused in
the past it changed her name
into delirium and even her current role
and lastly we have dream also known as
the sandman dream is typically presented
as a tall skinny guy with uncamped dark
hair he wears a formless night cloak
with flames dancing on its folds but we
rarely see that in the series he goes by
numerous names with morpheus being the
most common he is particularly focused
on carrying his obligations his dream
helm which was crafted from a long dead
god spine and skull served as his emblem
his ruby is his power but then he later
on absorbed that to himself and uses his
sand to travel wherever he wishes to
so that's about it that's the endless
from the dc universe and seen in the
latest netflix series the sandman so i
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well but most
of all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel
till the next one take care fam